[Music]
first of all phenomenal season last year
and uh then you just began the season
and already two home runs so it's like
you're picking up right where you left
off is that how it feels
i mean this year i think this is our
year to do some big things uh i feel
really great you know a couple of other
guys on the team andre d gordon you know
we got an exciting team it's gonna be a
good year you uh obviously the dodgers
have been through so much and now
there's this feeling that uh you guys
have the talent and there's also
uh new ownership yes uh and we should
talk about this magic johnson heading a
group that's buying the dodgers
a lot a lot of la people are really
excited about magic uh being part of the
dodgers uh
he definitely means a lot to the city of
los angeles and um you know it's great
to have him on the team because i know
he's gonna help us get to where we need
to be and that's you know winning some
baseball games you you don't lack
confidence you have said that you could
beat magic johnson one-on-one in
basketball definitely i think i can you
could yeah it's not your sport yeah i i
actually was going to go to college and
play basketball not a lot of people know
that but i can hoop a little bit man
okay all right well that chance he can't
beat me i promise you that he can't you
really say you you could take magic
johnson one on one it might be close
it'll be close it'll be close
does magic johnson know that you you've
seen he said he said to to some people
that uh he would beat me 15 to 7.
i think i'd i think i'd beat him 15 13.
15 13.
okay keep in mind he's keep in mind he's
he's your boss now
he is he is signing my check so yeah i
need to you know what imagine you can
beat me
that's that's not helping
i'll let you win um